how's it going brothers - welcome back
to some more Corpse Party with creepiest
[ __ ] game you ever played I
want to watch me play would you actually
get to play now ah my leg I can move it
so I guess it's just a spring I'm not a
home am i no you're not Cappy good okay
B plays a girl
all right look at it it's so dark I can
barely see a thing
this school is what's going on what the
hell is this place it's your school all
right so we can walk around finally all
right that's pretty awesome
oh is that psycho psycho psycho we can't
reach her this is a guy oh god it looks
like her eyebrows are like freaking out
or some [ __ ] well I guess we have no
choice but going here hopefully what we
won't die hasn't been a save yet so
that'd be Grady for what oh god I'm dead
I'm dead
ah that really hurt my ankle is in
pretty bad shape great that means if we
get chase were practically dead heavenly
post third student reported missing one
by one the young students of heavenly
host
xxxxX schools seem to be disappearing as
now a third student has joined the ranks
of the missing classmates testified that
fifth grader
was on her way home from school but gets
separated from her friends in the hall
and hasn't been seen since police are
investigating the possibility of a
serial kidnapping and have assigned
countless investigators to the case in
hopes of a speedy solution however ten
days have already passed since the first
disappearance giving parents and
classmates ample cause for concern some
I feel like that's related to what's
going on here I feel like the time will
be distorted and stuff in this game yes
alright sick sick huh thank goodness
she's still breathing
sick huh come on shake a Wicca Oh gadget
she's a bee Oh God all right Noemi wait
what's up don't you what's up me I
thought you were dead
oh oh wait where are we what's going on
that's what I like to know yep good
we're so dead prez I never okay psycho
okay
it ain't budgin these windows are still
up tight and it's pitch black out there
I can't make heads or tails what I'm
seeing what the hell is going on don't
[ __ ] swear well this is clearly a
school building don't the desks seem
unusually small to you though what why
what does that mean
like elementary school so we fell down
the floor maybe that's it an elementary
school took my second she's reading
what's your rating mine Koch what does
it say oh god what is going on what is
that the printer town in Devon it says
heavenly hosts elementary notice all
faculty and students oh my god what is
happening where the hell are we and
where are our friends and mrs. Q calm
down sicko don't get so worked up I'm
getting worked up here okay come on
I'm such a [ __ ] weeaboo Seiko and I
just stood there in silence
and oh my god I shipped them so much it
was the first time in my life that I've
been shaded so
I become completely lightheaded and
couldn't even think straight
much less wrap my brain around what was
happening to us I kept telling myself
it's all a dream some horrible nightmare
no matter how hard I wish for it
I just couldn't wake up I couldn't take
it anymore I had to say something
anything what is gonna happen yeah hey I
don't have the slightest idea what's
going on but how about we try finding a
way out of here way out we can't just
stand here quaking in terror we need to
do something you know besides I don't
want to be in this creepy place any
longer than I have to but our windows
are all sealed [ __ ] and I don't just
mean they're stuck or a lot it's like
they're decorations on the wall and I
don't even think they can open oh good
is it even possible to leave this
building I'm not sure but there might be
an entranceway or an emergency exit or
something some means of getting outside
I don't think so
you're right and it's a lot better than
just standing around I feel like I'm
going to go all loony in here if we keep
this up yes
yuck then first step is to leave this
room we got to keep our spirits up after
all it's probably not just the two of us
in here minami you come on Isaac
[Music]
the others have to be around here
somewhere right
yeah and if we can reunite with them
find a way out of here
together yeah that's the spirit
so watch Barry right now no reason to
believe any of that what I just said I
was probably delirious to be honest but
I knew that if I didn't act I start to
be go mad let's start to scream I'd be
inconsolable see some desperation I put
on the strongest front I could manage
you go girls
what is this so that was the character
introductions direct the eye towards any
character and press the X button to
learn more about him and her when you're
done exit through the door on the
southeast side of the room to resume
play okay that's a weird way to find out
about the characters I thought we just
did that for the last [ __ ] 40 minutes
but Jesus okay I guess I want to know
more about satoshi seventy year old
student in cancer Aggie Academy senior
fairly average but popular known for
being both kind and cowardly in equal
measure ha despite his timidness is very
personable and open which which
complements his general sensitivity
towards others make him a natural leader
let's find out about these two know me
and a six-year-old student frequent
reads Satoshi with oh not you again what
having lost her father a few years back
Naomi and her mother now depends on
another moral support
still she remains optimistic and
cherishing her her home life has given
her interest in nursing where she intent
on pursuing she spends her time studying
aiming for acceptance to medical
students okay you know what that's it
for now
sexy come on Irene let's go right
the spirit music is gonna turn you
quickly wait a second Oh guys ah another
earthquake isn't over let's just get out
of this boom hey what's wrong this
hallway looks totally different than it
did before so the earthquake changes it
yeah maybe probably not sure alright I
guess that means we can finally keep
moving gap is really narrow it seems
possible but it's a little too far to
risk jumping probably maze we're gonna
have to find something to put in between
there's a yellow fluid congealing inside
the rested pocket like oh god damn it
P it might be here don't say that
[Music]
I know this game gets really [ __ ]
like intense but it's also like weird
because it's so cute and like maybe
Newsies playing somewhere here hey now
me something wrong with your leg
oh yeah I was so freaked out I forgot
all about it I think I sprained my ankle
when I fell well that's not good will
you be okay I can walk at least I'm sure
I'll heal on its own yeah but you
shouldn't purchase yourself here lean on
my shoulder okay Matson don't worry bull
here's a loose board lying in the ground
take a video yes [ __ ] yeah a quiet loose
board - come with me [ __ ] that's right
girl that's right girl the loose board
coming with me yeah gotta poop that live
all around the turd gotta get the pee in
madam [ __ ] oh god damn it god damn it
it is put hey now me what about the list
board where else would you pick up a
loose board unless you knew it come on I
don't know it seems kind of beat-up but
I guess it's pretty solid try it the
loose board has been set in place one of
us is gonna die here I feel it not we're
alive both alive and fantastic
that looks [ __ ] creepy so let's not
go in there let's go in here
alright [ __ ] what is going on here he's
wait what huh you say something psycho
hmm yeah it wasn't you
it was all Bolivia boy come on I
definitely felt depresses of some kind
okay we can't go up there looks like the
creepy room it is hooray
I know a lot of people might say this
looks pretty weird or bad but I think it
looks really good I don't know for a RPG
maker however a game I guess I know it's
not anymore but ah okay what's wrong and
now me Oh God look over there aren't
those bones like people bones
why why why is there a dead person here
wait let me look at them more closely
why
maybe they're not real they're real okay
that real they're realer than okay not a
lot of things actually but they really
are somebody's bones
pull your [ __ ] together
you - what - you two are new victims are
you know I got ghosts who are you I was
brought here against my will and
confined just like you
confined so I get to ask you know where
here is so they'll ask about confinement
confine do you mean there's no way out
I'm afraid now school exists in a
reality all all its own caught off from
the wall you know so why have we been
brought here god they brought you
they're constantly bringing new victims
into this school more and more all the
time
sinless innocence one after another this
is a cursed multi-dimensional Nexus oh
yeah I know those multiple planes of
existence all piled on top of one
another created by powerful vengeful
spirits gatdam
clear space perhaps color space it you
and we are well are the unlucky victims
of an inescapable abduction closed
spaces in dude and it seems you two are
not the only wants to have been brought
here
I'm sensing numerous others it's just
that does that mean everybody else is
here too probably yes
senpai are they okay I wonder senpai so
our friends are in the school to I don't
know the exact number but I do know that
others were pulled into these spaces at
the same time as you they are definitely
in this school oh my god that's such
good news
now I'm ready where they're here we're
not alone that means mashiro's here too
I'll bet that makes you feel a lot
better right I don't know about that you
know ever you cannot meet them what they
are definitely in this school but the
space they occupy differs from this
space we occupy if you wish to see your
friends you must find some means of
entering this space their space or
bringing them into this space
oh that's nice even then escape is now
impossible but at least you'll be able
to die together that's that's very nice
thank you kindly blue a ball of
lightning of death oh good if there no
way out of here then you said we were
brought here by vengeful spirits right
who are they and why have they taken us
I don't know neither the motives or of
our captures nor a means of escaping
this huh all I know is that with some
effort you cannot leave leave out your
days together in the same space and that
alone is a fate worth fighting for
it sounds like goddammit two heads are
better than one your chances and your
opportunities are so much greater than
working together when working together
do whatever you can to find a way out of
here don't hand out like us oh god what
was that the door unlocked Oh what no oh
no help me run we have to get out of
here now oh good okay okay okay okay I'm
sorry my god I'm going alright good good
I'll [ __ ] that place [ __ ] that place
hard man bad pants oh are you all right
take oh yeah but what the hell was that
a child spirit it did kind of glow I
never believed in ghosts before this is
really happening there were definitely
ghosts in there first time I've seen
something like that
so you sorry too right
and we were talking to it I just I don't
understand any of that except that
there's no easy way out for us like it
or not we're stuck in here it'll be ok
let's just you know March home with our
heads held high or something
I love the music did it go down there go
down there girl can we take the page let
me take the ticket page
can I go now now why did we go in there
there's nothing there obviously let's
try it again
[ __ ] it yellow bright hopefully she's
not there anymore oh god she isn't I'll
thank heavens what is that this this is
here before I don't know but it's just a
picture right no it's not bunnies or
something I bet this is a safe stations
huh they're always a candle here I don't
think so but doesn't it look awfully
familiar save station fantastic we did
it okay cool that's very very very
similar to all day awesome
miss no running in the halls and it's
student caught running will be severely
disciplined yellow you can tell me what
the DOE law breaker 2014 can I go in
here
lot what is it saying admit it you hate
all your friends eventually you'll kill
one another
oh great thanks notes hi Tarek I hear
flies
follow me of another [ __ ] dead bodies
there I don't like that no sir I don't
like that at all girl oh god what the
[ __ ] what is that
Oh God alright Prez I'm gonna have to
end that one there thanks for leaving
like I really appreciate that I
appreciate all your support as always
it's rust for you see you tomorrow bus
lobby
[Music]